-And finally, thanks to
newly developed technology,
we here at "Late Night"
now have --
this is very exciting.
We now have the ability
to record the tiny voice
that is inside
Donald Trump's head.
And you might be surprised
to know that like
everyone's inner voice,
Donald Trump's is filled with
paralyzing fear and self-doubt.
So here it is, the tiny voice
in the back
of Donald Trump's head.
♪♪♪♪
-Thank you.
-Hey, Donald,
it's the tiny voice
in your head again.
And are you thinking
what I'm thinking?
Because it really seems like
your wife doesn't love you.
You know why I think that?
Because people who are in love
do not scowl
for all 24 hours of the day.
These people taking pictures
are going to crack
their iPhone screens with how
angry she looks all the time.
Hey, what was the last real
conversation you two had anyway?
Because the last thing
I remember
is election night when
she turned to you and said,
"Are you happy now?"
-And that's why I'm here today.
-Hey, by the way, who is
this guy talking right now?
And who is this woman who is
standing next to your wife?
What is going on?
You have no idea
where you are right now, do you?
No idea at all.
Oh, boy.
[ Cheers and applause ]